whether you've watched every disney and
the pixar movie or you just tuned into
phoenician ferp here and there for most
of us disney was a nostalgic part of our
childhood
and who could forget their iconic theme
parks that are scattered all around the
world while these factors are what most
of us remember about disney over the
past few decades they've grown into
basically every media industry you can
think of from marvel movies and star
wars to disney plus and espn disney owns
much of the modern media industry this
has put disney in a pretty unique
position as they can thrive in basically
any situation
if everyone is staying at home that's
perfect for disney streaming services
conversely if everyone is going out
that's perfect for their theme parks and
box office numbers
despite this unique advantage though
disney hasn't been doing well since the
pandemic started in fact their net
income crashed from roughly 10 billion
per year to as low as negative 5 billion
dollars per year
they have since become profitable again
but their current net income sits at
just a fraction of their pre-pandemic
numbers at two to three billion dollars
considering this i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that their stock has
gotten absolutely obliterated since
their peak in early 2021 disney stock
has fallen right about 50 which
correlates to a market cap loss of 188
billion dollars
so here's why disney is struggling on
wall street despite owning a media
empire and giving netflix a run for
their money
one of the biggest issues plaguing
disney is their underwhelming growth at
least from the perspective of investors
likely the most disappointing sector for
investors is disney plus
this is honestly quite ironic given that
disney plus has been killing it ever
since they launched they've literally
grown from zero to
137.7 million subscribers within a
matter of two and a half years for
perspective it has taken netflix 15
years to grow to 200 million subscribers
but while this is phenomenal growth many
investors are worried about how disney
plus will perform in a post-pandemic
world last year we actually got a small
taste of what may be ahead for disney
plus and it wasn't that optimistic if we
zoom back to q3 and q4 or 2021 we'll see
that disney plus subscriber numbers
barely moved from 116 million to
118.1 million this means that they only
gained a 2.1 million subscribers this
entire quarter which was a far cry from
investor expectations of at 9 million
new subscribers
but wait a minute why was subscriber
growth so slow near the end of the year
well the thing to keep in mind is that
disney's fiscal quarters don't exactly
line up with the tax quarters that we're
familiar with our first quarter is
actually disney second quarter our
second quarter is disney's third quarter
and so on and so forth so when disney
reports their third and fourth quarters
of 2021 they're actually talking about
the second and third quarters of 2021 so
basically the peak of summer going into
fall as you would guess this is when
people are most likely to travel and
partake in social events given that
school is off and the weather is nice so
it makes sense that disney's subscriber
codes slow down substantially during the
summer months of 2021. if we look
further into the graph we'll see that
subscriber growth picked up again in the
winter months of 2021 and the start of
2022 when omar kwon was a big concern
but as we approached the summer again
investors are worried that disney plus
may post subpar growth numbers once
again this fear is made even worse when
you consider that most people haven't
really gone anywhere since the pandemic
started meaning that we'll likely see
above average travel this summer
something else to consider is that many
subscribers got disney plus specifically
because they had nothing better to do
during the pandemic but as they return
to normal life many of them are
cancelling it's also not a great sign
that netflix just posted their first
subscriber loss in a decade of 200 000
subscribers not to mention they'd think
that these losses are going to get even
worse as we move into the summer
now disney has maintained a more
positive long-term outlook projecting
that they can still reach 230 to 260
million subscribers by september of 2024
but at this point to reach this goal
disney would have to consistently
achieve 11 to 12 million new subscribers
every quarter and the issue is that
disney has only posted one quarter in
the 11 to 12 million range since the end
of 2020. so many investors are rather
skeptical about denny's projections
prompting them to leave in droves
all right so it looks like disney plus
is going to take a hit within the next
few quarters but fortunately as we
discussed at the beginning disney is a
multifaceted business that can thrive in
a multitude of environments
if people are going out more that's
perfect for disney's theme parks and
their box office numbers right well the
answer is yes and noah disney has indeed
been crushing it in these sectors for
example ria out of the four best opening
weekends of 2021 belonged to disney
similarly disney has been posting
tremendous year-over-year growth as high
as 99 for their parks and experiences
disney's revenue is basically back to
pre-pandemic levels in fact the last
quarter of 201 was their best quarter
ever in terms of revenue the only
problem though is that these impressive
revenue figures haven't translated to
their bottom line their net income is
still only about a fifth of what used to
be pre-pandemic and if we look at their
net margin this downtrend becomes
extremely clear disney's net margin has
plummeted from over twenty percent to
just three percent and the main reason
for this is skyrocketing operating
expenses which can be traced back to two
factors starting with a massive staffing
shortage as you would guess disney laid
off tens of thousands of employees when
the pandemic rolled around but they
weren't able to fill in these vacancies
as demand recovered in fact disney's
total employee count has decreased for
two years at this point and the given
that demand is quickly recovering to
pre-pandemic levels disney is having to
increase pay substantially to fill in
vacant positions this issue is made even
worse given that 25 000 employees are
actually suing disney to pay better now
i'm by no means trying to suggest that
this battle is or is not justified but
regardless of the morality of the fight
increasing pay is not the best for
disney's bottom line or disney stock
aside from struggling to find employees
disney has also been struggling against
inflation by now i'm sure you're all
well aware of how bad inflation is and
this issue affects disney just like the
rest of us they have to pay for more
supplies food transportation talent
energy and so on and so forth
fortunately disney has great pricing
power when it comes to their parks and
experiences meaning that they can
increase prices and people will still
pay them but with that being said
raising prices across the board is not
the best idea and for obvious reasons
disney wants to address this issue as
strategically as possible disney cfo
announced that they're looking into
switching suppliers substituting
products and cutting portion sizes
wherever possible to minimize price
increases something else to note is that
while disney may have great pricing
power when it comes to their parks and
experiences they don't have that much
pricing power when it comes to disney
plus you see people are often okay with
splurging on the occasional vacation but
they're way more sensitive to price
increases in monthly subscriptions this
price sensitivity has made it extremely
difficult for disney to continue
doubling down on streaming while also
maintaining a low subscription cost i do
believe that disney will eventually
figure it out but in the meantime
re-staffing and inflation has destroyed
their net margin
aside from these fundamental issues that
are being reflected in disney's
quarterly reports a major factor that is
holding back many investors from
investing in disney is their apparent
wokeness i mean it's no secret that
disney has always leaned towards a more
liberal perspective and this has become
especially evident within the past
couple of years their movies and medias
promote lgbtq quite openly as there's
dozens of references sprinkled
throughout their films this has prompted
many parents to re-evaluate whether they
want their children to be exposed to
this content at an early age now i'm
sure there's going to be plenty of
comments down below that say go woke go
broke and honestly this is a pretty
accurate statement and i'm not trying to
single out being woke if disney was
leaning to the right it would be the
same argument companies should simply
not be involved in politics the truth is
regardless of which side you choose or
how careful you are with your stances
you're naturally going to enrage a
significant portion of the population so
as a company it's best to stay out of
politics and hot topics in general and
just focus on running your business well
but unfortunately disney is actively
doing the exact opposite for example a
few months ago florida's governor ron
desantis signed a rather controversial
law that many call the don't say gay
bill if you're not familiar with this
bill it basically outlaws classroom
instruction regarding gender identity
between kindergarten through third grade
right after this news came out disney
decided that it was a great idea to
publicly announce that they were not
only against this law but that it was
their goal as a company to repeal this
legislation again their stance regarding
this issue doesn't really matter if they
came out in full support of the bill it
would have been just as bad for the
company because investors don't like
controversial companies from their
perspective controversy simply threatens
future growth and at this point disney
has gone pretty far down that road
at the end of the day disney definitely
does have some internal issues they're
having to fight against inflation and
staff shortages while also trying to
keep prices as low as possible they're
also having trouble reaching some of
their ambitious growth targets
especially with disney plus but honestly
i don't think any of these are a game
changer for disney's overall business
after all it's not like disney plus is
doing bad and it's not like inflation
and staffing concerns are specific to
disney personally i think it's just a
matter of time until disney recovers
from these short-term issues and starts
to post solid profits once again
something that is a game changer however
is their political entanglement at this
rate it's just a matter of time until
investors right off disney all together
as a company that's too political to
invest in like twitter if you look at
twitter's revenue for example it's
really only gone up if we look at
twitter's talk however it hasn't moved
in a decade and unfortunately this might
be the path that disney is going down as
well if we put their political
entanglement aside though disney is
looking quite nice in my opinion in one
of their recent earnings calls disney
even teased the idea of a disney
metaverse that is supposed to connect
their digital and physical offerings
more than ever before
now this was simply a tease and we have
no idea how well this plan will work out
or if it'll even end up happening but
from an investor's perspective it's
great to see that disney is looking to
embrace new technology it shows that the
company is still trying to innovate and
that they probably won't stagnate
fundamentally anytime soon so personally
i think disney is a solid investment at
100
if you're going to take on the political
risk but that's just what i think and
it's not financial advice what do you
guys think about disney's awokeness
comment that down below
also drop a like if disney is nostalgic
for you and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
your videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one